>> Hello everyone. Welcome to
the final intern talk today.
Today, we have Ben who was
working with us all summer.
Worked really hard
on a new problem.
So, it's my pleasure to
introduce Ben who's
a PhD student at CMU.
He works under the supervision
of Professor Bigsha Raj.
His current research
is focused on machine
learning for Audio and previously
he was a staff researcher at
ICSI at UC Berkley and
he's done a lot of work
on Audio understanding and
multimedia problems in
the past and today,
he's going to talk about
his final internship project on
a cross-modal Audio search engine
based on joint
audio text embedding.
So, with that please welcome Ben.
>> Thank you Shuayb for
the introduction and thank you
everyone for coming here,
I know that everyone is busy
so I appreciate your time.
So, let's start with
presenting and
introducing the topic.
First, we have that there are
many multimedia and
audio recordings
that are captured every day.
All of these recordings carry
information specifically
in this talk,
we're talking about
the acoustic information.
There are sounds, soundscapes,
there's information that tell us
what's going on in
this recordings.
There are recordings
that are captured
and shared in
social media, for example,
where people typically
will have some words or
descriptions to describe what's
going on in the content.
But, on the other hand, there's
also recordings like from
Amazon Echo or Alexa
and these devices,
also surveillance camera,
customer services,
recordings et cetera,
where no one takes the
time to label or annotate
what sounds or what audio
it's in the content.
So, if we have this recordings,
it's very complicated to
do search and retrieval.
So, what people typically
do is to approach
their problem with either
text or audio similarity.
So, let's say for
example that we have
a query on the left and we have
a pool of information of
audio and associated
labels on the right.
If we take the query,
that X Query cat,
we're going to be able to
retrieve the first and
the third recording because
they're properly labeled.
In the same way, if we
have an audio that
corresponds to cat,
we can retrieve the first and
the third and the last one,
even though the last one
doesn't have the level of cat,
but acoustically
they are similar.
On the other hand, if
we pass an audio and
then we are able to
retrieve the green algae
from the pool,
but then in this case we
don't have tags, right?
So, in this case, we use
acoustic similarity,
but we don't have tag
associated to that sound.
So, we don't know what
is the content of
the sound until we
actually listen to it.
This might be easy for
certain sounds like
God where there are
some other acoustics and sounds
that are more
complicated to decipher
without some contexts and there's
also people with
disabilities who cannot
listen to the audio
and infer the label.
So, one solution
that is common in
the literature is to
generate text metadata for
these audio recordings using
automatic speech recognition or
sound event detection that
is their labeled for
sounds assigned to segments
of their recording.
Now, what we propose
here and what
we tried this summer was
a growth model approach.
We aim for two main goals
in this approach.
The first one is to map
audio and text into the
same shared latent space.
That will benefit
us because then,
audio and texts
can be comparable.
So, if we pass a Query,
that is a text or
an audio recording,
we can map it to
that joint space and
find the neighbors that
correspond to that recording.
The second and most
important I think is that
the shared space should preserve
semantic similarity between
the text and the audio.
So, typically, as I was saying,
the approaches will be
designed separately,
text and audio, but here,
we want to combine both meaning,
the acoustics similarity and
the semantic similarity.
For example, if we have that
the words "violin breaks"
and "violin plays",
those two are semantically
speaking in terms of
language similar because
they refer to a violin.
But, if we think of
the acoustics of
the sounds that they will
produce, they're different.
So, we hope and we aim
that these joint space
we'll find a middle
point to preserve
that similarity or that text
and the audio at the same time.
Okay, so the rest of the talk is
about the approach that
we follow to create
this joint and space and how
well those joint representations
will for classification
and also for retrieval.
When it comes to related work,
we selected mainly three papers
and the first one is,
it described an approach
for search and
retrieval using text
and audio queries.
Although this was
a fast approach,
it was developed in
an independent way where
text and audio were trained
separately and then at
some point they will combined to
assign a score and then
retrieve information
based on those scopes.
That approach didn't work
without a vocabulary words.
Then the second
approach from Malcolm,
he created a semantic space
with text like
a hierarchy and then
on the acoustic space,
they cluster audio and then
they linked those two spaces,
but this approach, it's hard to
scale because you need to
create these associations
and clusters.
Then, on the third approach,
we actually look at
computer vision and we found
that there's
some papers that refer
to image and text embeddings
where they tried to
approach the problem in
a similar way that we described.
So, the approach that we have
and that we are going to use
across this presentation
is the Siamese Network.
The Siamese Network, the overall
idea I'll explain more
of the details after.
The overall idea is
that it will take
audio and text one on each gap
and you will take
positive and negative
pairs and the positive,
that means that the text and
the audio correspond
to the same class and
negative pairs mean
that the text and
the audio corresponds
to a different class.
So, we will use these pairs
to train this network.
Then at the end, at the top,
the loss function is trying to
make the two modalities that
correspond to the same class
to be closer to each other and
the two modalities
that correspond to
the same class to be separate.
Then at the embedding stage,
once we have this
neural network train,
we will be able to feed
either audio text and then
create joined representations
or embeddings.
So, we can see the output
of those embeddings
as an intermediate feature
that takes in the audio space.
So, what we typically will feed
to the neural network
are features.
In this case, for example,
we used audio features
which are MFCC,
it's a good standard feature
for this task.
Since we needed a vector,
we basically computed the mean of
the entire MFCC matrix
corresponding
to each of the other
recordings and
then we created
mean vectors across time.
The similar approach with
the text, we used Word2Vec.
Word2Vec, if you're not
familiar with that,
is a technique to convert
one word into a numerical vector,
but those vectors preserve
a semantic similarity.
So, words that are similar
will exist in the vectors with
the close distance and
words that are different
will exist further apart.
So, the dimensionality that
we use for our audio and text
features were 300.
This is basically the setup
that we use for most of our work.
Then the input and
the configuration of
a Siamese network
was the following; first,
we pass the features
as I described before
and we assign a zero or a one,
depending if we pass in
negative or positive first.
Then this network is
basically the same,
that's why they
call them Siamese,
it's exactly the same and
they share parameters,
and it was a simple BNN
and the output was 1,024,
that is the dimensionality
of our embeddings.
Then once we have
the embeddings from
other embedding from text,
this is training time.
We're going to pass
it to the part where
we enforce the similarity
between modalities.
>> So, the parameters you said
in the previous line from
the final parameters you picked,
after doing other experiment,
why did you pick those 1,024?
Because they performed
best? Why was the network-
>> Oh yeah. The
network parameters?
Yes, so I basically
carry on some tuning,
started with one layer and
then change in the number of
nodes and number of layers
in powers of two and after
spend us a reasonable
of time tuning,
this was the best performance.
But there's more
explanation to be done.
Okay. So, this is
the most important part of
the neural network because here,
the letter to basically
work with this combo,
the contrastive loss
and the L2 distance.
The goal of these contrastive
loss is, as I say,
to enforce that pairs that
correspond to a similar class
closer and different class
to be separate.
It does it using
the part that we see on
the right, which is a margin.
DW is the distance for
similarity and when
we have similar data,
we want the pairs,
we want them to be close
within the margin,
M. M is a hyperparameter
that we also tune.
The problem is that
this actually didn't
work for our data.
So, we try some other
similarity techniques
and distance and also
another loss function.
So, at the end, the combination
that performed the
best was the binary cross-entropy
which also has a binary setup.
But now, the distance,
we use the exponential
minus L1 or L2.
The best one was minus L2.
Here, you have to think that
the L2 and L1 as they are,
they have an unbounded
score, right?
So, if it's very similar,
then it's a small number and if
it's very large, it
can grow very high.
But if we use the
negative exponential,
then we force the distance
to be a number between,
remember that if you
look at the plots,
it look like this, the
exponential with
a negative inside.
So, if they are similar,
we're going to have one
and if they are different,
it will be a number
close to zero.
So, now we have
pluralistic framework there.
This one show the best results
that I'm going to show
later in a different slide.
>> What is the role of
the second parameter in BCE?
The first is the divergence.
>> The BCE?
>> Yes. 1 minus y_i
logarithm of 1 minus D_w.
>> Remember, we're passing
first with zero and one.
So, one will take care of
one class and the other one
will take care of
the other class.
>> So, y_i can be zero or one?
>> Yeah.
>> So, if y_i is zero,
the first down zero and then
the second last will be
used and then if y_i
is one, then the-
>> It's a binary. Okay.
>> Yeah, so I know you
said it's binary for
both of them, right?
Because we were with
first zero or one.
>> Can you explain why
do we use exponential?
Why not hyperbolic tangent,
tan edge function to
do the compression?
>>Yes. So, in this case,
as I was saying, we chose
this one because it
gives you a number
from one to zero.
We could also use
the cosine similarity or
any other combination but
we just try these
combinations, right?
But certainly, something
else can be explore for
the distance and also for
the binary setup in
the loss function.
But there is no specific reason
why we shouldn't
try the other ones.
So, this is the combo
that we chose.
Now, I just explain how we
train the network and now,
let's go to the data
and the experiments.
So, the data that we use,
this is a dataset that
was released this summer.
It contains audio recordings
corresponding to Freesound.
Freesound, if you're
not familiar,
is basically like a YouTube
for audio where we can find
sounds and tags and users
upload their their recordings.
We have 9,000 recordings
and the duration is up
to three seconds, single-channel.
Now, for the text,
all of these audio recordings
are associated with
a text label which were
chosen from the
audio set ontology.
It's a hierarchy of 527 classes
but for this dataset,
they only chose 41 from
different categories.
Some of the classic examples
are these ones that we
have that can be an instrument,
sounds of animals,
sounds of humans, sounds
from just everyday life.
We explore using
that texts with single class
labels and also
simulated noisy text
by adding random Gaussian noise
with one or two Sigma.
We'll explain this
a little bit more
in the future slides.
Therefore, classification
and retrieval,
we try these two
statistical models,
but most of the work is
done with nearest neighbor.
Well, let me show the next slide.
>> It's 30 seconds
and then you average
all the features within
those 30 seconds?
>> Yes.
>> That's it?
>> Yeah. So, if we
300 milliseconds and then
the audio is a matrix that
depend on how you extract,
if it represented
300 milliseconds,
we just average over
time and then we get
just one single vector
for each audio recording.
>> I didn't get the connection
between result and audio set.
>> Right. So, the authors
of the dataset,
what they did is that they chose
41 classes from audio set.
>> In Freesound?
>> No. First you choose-
Right, but just the labels.
So, they took the ontology
from audio set,
not the data, just the ontology.
>> Audio and text.
>> Exactly, and then they
use those classes to
download audio from
Freesound and then
they clean the data.
>> I see. So, you do
have a description of
the Freesound files but using
the dictionary from audio set.
>> Exactly. If you
use audio from video,
it tends to be very
noisy and it's
harder to clean and also,
the rest of the metadata
is not precisely
associated to [inaudible]
it's a more complex problem.
This one, they tried to clean
the whole setup to make
it easier to explore.
>> The labels?
>> The label is
from the audio set.
So, the audio set has
this ontology, has 527 labels.
They chose 41 based on
whatever system they have.
Once they have the label,
they went to Freesounds,
they query those sounds,
collected 9,000
recordings distributed
across the 41 classes and
then there was a dataset.
>> So, pretty much
each Freesound file
carries one or more labels
from that group of 41 classes?
>> Yeah, a good
question. Audio set
actually has
a multi-level problem.
Here, they ensure that there's
only one of those 41 classes.
>> So, each file
carries one class?
>> Carry one annotated class.
There might be
some other sounds there.
So, let's say that you have
one recording with drums,
it will be labeled as drums.
However, there may be
a violin playing there.
Well, in this case,
we have violin.
Let's say there's birds
chirping, that will
not be annotated.
>> But you do have
drums and violin and
you label it as drums only?
>> Yes.
>> Whichever is dominant?
>> Yes, the dominant.
>> For this classification,
is this came with
Freesound or you did
the labeling by
yourself by running
the audio set classifier?
>> No. This was done by
the- This is a DK dataset.
>> This is a DK dataset that
already was already collated.
>> It was collated by, actually,
the people who are in charge of
Freesound and the people who
are in charge of audio set.
So, they basically team up
and came up with this one.
>> They had one
reviewer to annotate?
>> Yes, so they do a revision.
I don't know, they don't
say in the website.
I don't know if it's just one
or they have three of them.
Then they assign a number of
confidence whether
they actually detected
the sound inside
the recording or not.
Most of them are very
properly verify and
actually accurate,
but not all of them.
>> So, there are high chances
that your data challenging
to view. right?
>> Exactly. Good?
So, this is the data.
So, the first experiment
that we tried was to see
how well the embeddings from
the Siamese actually work
in comparison to
just the handcrafted MFCC
features, the audio features.
What we did here,
only for this experiment,
was to train the Siamese network
only using audio first,
no text involved.
So, we would use pairs of
value corresponding
to the same class,
or pairs of value corresponding
to different classes.
So we have all our
training audio,
we computed our MFCCs,
and then we train
the Siamese network.
Then in the embedding
stage we pass all
our audio set that
were 9,000 recordings.
We computed MFCCs, and then
using the trained
Siamese network,
we computed what we call
the audio solo embeddings.
So, these solo
embeddings they come
intermediate features or
embeddings coming from
the trained Siamese network.
In the evaluation stage,
we treat these first
as a classification
problem and then we use
our embeddings that we
created and do
a classification task,
train and tested
it, independently.
The performance that
we got here comparing
the handcrafted features and
embedding is the following.
There are two main
takeaways here.
I'll help you go
through the slide.
One is that, the MFCCs and
the embeddings from
the Siamese network,
they will perform incomparably.
That means the
discriminative power of
the embeddings was comparable
to just the handcrafted MFCCs.
The second is that,
we use KNN and we
tune the K parameter,
and also we use SVM linear and we
tune the parameters inside.
We're basically seeing
that the performance
with handcrafted features and
embeddings were comparable.
We decided to pick the KNN
because it provides
a better framework
for the idea of
having a neighborhood
of embeddings.
That way it will be easier to
present the retrieval
results later on.
>> So, let me
understand the number.
You have 50ish percent
classification accuracy
on four Q1 classes.
>> Correct.
>> Using 9500, why
did you not use something more
sophisticated than SVR and KNN?
Like a KNN network core?
>> We used that also.
Similar in performance.
>> Seriously?
>> Yeah, but this-
>> It wasn't that
good, that means.
>> So, I try an MLT
with two, three,
four layers, and it was
performing similarly to
these with audio embeddings.
The problem is that, that one
was taking longer to train,
and also there are so many
parameters that can be tuned.
That we just stick
to these two because
it's easier to tune,
and again, the performance
was comparable.
I'm sure if we will try
a more complicated neural network
instead of these to classifier,
we can improve performance. Yeah.
>> I have one question
about the MFCC.
So, you chose one MFCC vector
for the entire
sampling. On average.
>> Correct.
>> Did you think
about other ways of
summarizing those MFCC vectors?
>> Yeah, Yeah. So, we
can do super vectors
or ai vectors in
any other approach certainly.
>> Because our only data
about the dynamics of
the signal you have is
averaging the deltas
and decibels also.
>> Right.
>> It gives something,
but not much.
>> Right. Yeah. So, there can be
better ways to represent
the matrix as a vector actually.
Later on we use
better features to show.
We will show the
performance. We also- Yeah?
>> Still, from two and
a half chance to
51 percent, hey, it's something.
>> Yeah, that's true.
>> So, picking the classifier
was not the important point.
The point that we're
trying to make
here is the embeddings,
do they perform the same
as the raw features?
>> Yeah.
>> So, it looks
like your features
are pretty efficient, right?
If DNN was also
performing similarly,
it looks like your features are.
>> Yeah, consistent
across classic likes.
>> So, if you like
something does features.
>> Back in here would have
been the dark blue line
were 20 percent and
the light blue one
line were 50 percent.
Then, that's bad, that
means that the Siamese
you had hadn't worked.
Just want to be sure.
>> Exactly. Exactly.
We will not be able to justify
releasing this context
going through the extra effort
of their computing
the embeddings if we cannot
beat them with simple MFCCs.
Anyway, so, wait.
So, now we have
the joint approach.
In this case, now we
actually use audio and text.
Firstly, take our audio and
text, the training set.
We compute our vectors of MFCCs,
and our Word2Vec, for text.
Then, we train the
Siamese network
the way that I described before.
So, now we pass
all our audio recordings,
compute the MFCC's, and
compute the audio
joint embeddings, right?
So, these joint embeddings
again come from
a trained network that was
used in audio and text.
We did the same for the text.
For the text, we computed
a text issues, Word2Vec,
and then we pass it through
exactly the same trained
Siamese network,
and we compute our text
joint embeddings.
So, now we have
intermediate representation
for the audio and for the text.
Then the same setup
where we have
our classification task,
but now we're going to show
the cross modality experiments.
Cross-modal experiments.
So first, so here what
I want to show is
how the handcrafted features
compare to the joint embeddings.
In the top row, we have
training only on the means
of the MFCCs and then test
them on the means of MFCCs.
Train and test false.
Then, on the right train
only on the text,
which are the Word2Vec vectors,
and train them, the Word2Vec,
and test on the MFCCs.
So, the performance is 49.7,
which is similar to the to
the bars that I
showed you before.
Then, 2.4 is
a random performance,
because basically the features
are independent, right?
We have MFCCs and Word2Vec,
they are unrelated.
So, we expect it to
have the internal doc.
>> So, later you try to
synthesize the sounds from?
>> Text.
>> Exactly.
>> It's not possible.
>> That's what we're
trying to solve.
>> Except for those
onomatopoeia words, right?
>> Yeah, for that too.
>> Right. [inaudible]
>> But if, seriously,
If you had only those words you
should get better than chance.
>> But we don't have those words.
>> Yeah, okay.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I have
to think of other ones.
That's true. Anyway, so
these are the results when we
actually use the joint embedding.
So, for audio joint embeddings
train and test,
we get a slightly
better performance.
Therefore, for
embeddings of text so we
train the nearest networks
with embeddings from
text and then we test it
with embeddings of audio.
Now, that the performance
was not random,
it was actually comparable
that if we will
have a just an audio-audio setup.
Okay. So, this is one of
the main results
we're we actually
show that cross modality,
cross-modal embeddings,
can actually be used
for train and test.
>> So, question.
Does it mean that
the embedding represents better
the audio or is based
mostly on audio, you know?
>> Yeah. So, it sees
the embedding improved,
and my intuition is
because now we're adding
the text information,
so we basically adding
another modality on top.
That's helping us
improve this one.
Of course, that one
has the help of
the audio when we train
the Siamese network.
So, now we are making
the embeddings comparable,
which was one of the main goals.
>> So, to answer, to
more addition to that,
the answer is the test
was on audio-audio here.
You can also test on
only text features.
The rows could be test on
text in addition to that.
So, ideally we would want all
four of them of them to be
to give 50 percent.
So, there are some
complications in that,
but we'll show you.
>> There's a complicated part.
>> So, if it's only
50 percent, then it's perfect.
That's what we want. All four
of them should be 50 percent.
>> Exactly. That would
be the ideal case.
>> So, can we prove
that the embedding is
or isn't biased towards
the audio space versus the text?
>> Yeah. If it's all equal
then you can conclude that.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> We'll see.
>> We'll see. But that's
a good question because,
I'll touch that topic
in a few slides.
So, in order to
compute these results,
I just want to show a couple of
interesting things
when it comes to
training the Siamese Network.
One is that this is what you see
in the Audio Joint Embeddings,
audio with audio.
Then, we can see how
the number of pairs
that we use actually
affected a performance.
Depending on how much data
we have, these can explode.
So, it's important to know
the minimal amount
of pairs that we
need to do this training.
Then, these are the results,
also again, with
the Audio Joint Embeddings.
This is how the performance
differ or varies
with the different combinations
of loss and similarity.
We ended up using the
one on the bolded.
Okay. So, now we go to the text.
Before that, I added
this extra row here,
which the only
difference is that,
now I added the better
audio features.
They come from a complex
CNN architecture
using log Mel-Frequency features
and then pass to the CNN.
Then, it has seven layers,
convolutional layers with
max pooling et cetera.
Then, the output where
these features that we use.
They were also a vector
that we pass to a Siamese.
Basically, if we have
better features,
where your features, we
can improve the
performance. All right.
>> Is that CNN decase winners?
>> No. This actually
from a paper.
This information is
from a few members of
our group and
their performance analysis
was comparable to the
state-of-the-art there.
>> So, we could use decase
of the audio studies?
>> Yes.
>> I think that's what Ari
used in a curious state.
>> Yes. So, where do we use this
because we had this axis?
>> So, there's one author who
participated in both papers that
work for Carrier and this one.
But, it's not this example.
>> So, that is maybe
your version of.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Anyway, so,
but the point is that if
you improve your features,
you also can improve
your embeddings.
Then so, now let's go to
the cross modality with text.
>> But you should explain what
is the gutch in the text?
Why is this text
not an ideal text?
>> Yeah. So, there's one thing
that I didn't touch to it,
so the text here.
We know that we have
9,000 recordings and we
have a text label associated
to each of the recordings.
We have 41 classes so
that text is basically
the same text for
the recordings in
training and in testing.
Does that makes sense?
So, that means that the
data that we have
a training time,
we also have it at testing time.
So, what we will expect
here, is that again,
this is a random number
because we're
training on audio and
testing on Word2Vec.
These are completely independent
or related features.
They were going to have
100% there because we have
the same data for
training and testing.
>> Just to clarify, that labels
were cat in training, cat,
cat, cat, and in testing
also they were cat, cat cat.
>> Right.
>> But in reality,
they're not like that.
The tags are, cat, cat,
kitten, a small kitten,
all of that, right?
Then, the testing tags are
slightly different than that.
But in our case, in this
experiment, they were the same.
So that's why we've
achieved that percent.
>> But usually campaign
process the text is been
done it's a [inaudible] process in
speech recognition area in the-
>> Yeah, but if you do
that, you won't get a 100%.
What I'm saying is
if there's noise in
the test tags, it
won't be a 100%.
That's the answer
why we have a 100%.
>> Exactly. Thanks. Exactly.
So then, under this premise,
we wanted to see how well
the joint embeddings perform
given that we do have the same
text in training and test.
But we were passing it
through the embeddings first.
So the Siamese network first.
So, we were able to
achieve 100% in both.
Now, this one we
were competing audio features
with audio text in Siamese.
So we see the text,
the label indirectly when
training the Siamese but not
directly because it's
not in the training.
However, we still achieve 100%.
Then, in the other one, it does
make sense there is
100 because we have
joint embeddings that
are exactly the same
in training and test.
This trend is the same when
we use better RB features.
Now, this is.
>> More real case.
>> More rehab case.
So our moral case, so we
added the simulated
noise to the text.
We generated random
Gaussian noise
with one and two Sigmas.
So that will mean,
there is one Sigma
is more noisy than
the original text features,
and two Sigmas will
be even noisier.
The way that we add
the noise is that
when we compare with
the Word2Vec embeddings,
we add the noise to that vector.
It will be different noise
to every single
one of the 9,500 recordings.
>> So you don't have noise on
the texts, you don't alter?
>> No. So we add in the vectors.
Also contrary, we
could have just gone
wild and changed some text
but we didn't know,
we wouldn't know how
it's reflecting this.
That's why this is the first.
If we are also going to
add random text word also
eventually, we'll see that.
>> Is that up there,
way of adding noise
because that assumes that
your Word2Vec representation
maps similar work.
>> Yes, that's how it
works. If you take
cat, and if you take kitten,
and you compute Word2Vec for
both of them, it's not zero.
There is some finite distance
and that distance is small.
>> Okay.
>> But if you take cat,
and if you take bus,
and if you take, the
distance is large.
Now, we could add
some random words to cat,
the cat and a set
of text and then do
the Word2Vec for that.
But you won't have
the control of the amount
of mice in the Word2Vec.
>> Yeah, I'm just asking is
that I don't know how does
Word2Vec come up with this?
Is that just trained on
some large database?
>> Yeah, this one is
specifically strained
in the Wikipedia,
and it's trying to
estimate how likely is
that you have a word
in a given context.
>> Is there any reference
that says that noise,
all the distribution you
get is somehow Gaussian?
Like you take a word
like cat and then.
>> No, we just assume that it is.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> But it is fake.
>> Gaussian noise is always fake.
>> This is just experiment.
Eventually you want to use this.
>> Yeah.
>> Just curious how
does this compute
with words that are very similar
but in very different meaning,
like cat and mat, for example.
>> You mean, the score?
>> Work to that or do they
like very close because the
word is similar or is there
some associated context like
the meaning is very different
so the distance is different?
>> Yeah, so, the
semantic similarity in
the text will be learned
from the context of the large
corpus that it was chosen.
So, let's say an example that
I will make of right now is
that you will say I pet
the cat and I pet the kitty.
So those two,
they will happen very
often in the same context,
those two words.
So they will exist in
a very closest space
in the Word2Vec space.
If you compute similarity,
you can use any
similarity technique,
cosine similarity for example,
and they will give you a score
from minus one to one,
where one is the most similar.
They are risk and having
exactly the same word
and minus one will be
very different words.
For example, if you
had cat and cats,
they will be close,
but not exactly the same, right?
Cat and kitty. Anyway,
so, where were we?
Okay, so with just the noisy.
>> Boarding. Sir yeah, we can go.
>> Anyway, so, we
just added the noise
here the way that we discussed.
Now, we do again
the cross-modal experiment.
Now, I'm presenting this
in a different way,
so we have the four combinations
that we show in the table before.
Here, we have no noise,
noise with 1 Sigma,
noise with 2 Sigma.
So, at least in this
and the third case
adding noise that
didn't really affect
the performance of
the joint embeddings,
but I think the noise
where we actually
have to test on text,
it actually degraded performance.
Now, this can give us an idea
of how we could perform
work if we actually use that text
or some noisy text, right?
So, this was just to
test the extent of
the joint embeddings.
>> Did the audio add
some noise in it?
>> No, we did not add
any noise to the audio
because it was already
there while recording,
so they're already
acoustic diverse described.
Okay, so then in summary,
just to summarize,
this is what we use
the joint embedding from
cross-modal classification
and now we want
to see how it performs
with retrieval.
So, in the retrieval case,
we basically have
a similar approach.
Now, we use the base study
features, we train,
we use the same train
Siamese Network from before,
and then we created our other
joint embeddings again.
This is a TSNE plot
which is basically
a mapping of the train vectors,
audio training vectors
to the plot.
Is like applying PCA to
a large dimensionality and
just reduce it in
order to plot it.
>> Is it TSNE plot?
>> Yeah, TSNE, T-S-N-E.
>> Okay.
>> I don't know if that
how they pronounce it.
Anyway, so what we
did here first is
to do a qualitative analysis
where we pass a text query,
we just define a text query,
and then we pass it through
the entire pipeline
and then at the end,
we have our text train embedding
for that text work.
Then we use the train
nearest neighbors to see which
are the neighbors, right?
Let's say, in this case,
we use a text
and we want to see
where are the audios,
the audio recordings that
are near to that text query.
So, let me guide you
through this table.
First, this is for
out-of-vocabulary words,
for words that are not
in the 41 classes.
These are the text query
that we use and those other
retrieve results
from the Audio Pool.
So, in this case we have
audio joint embedding.
>> So, you bring
additional information here
from the algorithm
for word to texts.
>> Word to text?
>> Out-of-the-vocabulary,
means a label which is
not in the 41 class.
>> Exactly.
>> But you bring
a different additional rotation,
how close is this to the classes
by Word2Vec by
the training of Word2Vec.
>> Right.
>> Because they should be
some external
information like that
>> Exactly. So, they explained on
this universal Wikipedia
part classes.
It captures the whole language,
English language.
>> Yeah.
>> In some sense.
>> So, is that a vocabulary
from our approach,
releasing the vocabulary
of the Word2Vec users.
Here, we use the word "applause",
literally typed the word
"applause" and then from
that pool of audio embeddings,
these were the retrieved results,
which seems reasonable
for applause.
For bark these were the
words that we retrieve.
For gunshot will retrieve this
once and I mean
that the neighbors
were an audio that had
a gunshot as a label
an audio that had
the fireworks as a label
and so on and so forth.
But notice that, if we
will have relied only on
the distance of Word2Vec
just a text distance,
we will have retrieved
these words.
But these are difference
because we are retrieving
based on text and audio distance.
Right? So, in this case.
>> [inaudible] related to
applause? Just kidding.
>> In some ways.
>> It's close.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. But this means that is
closer from within
the 41 classes.
Right? Now that is actually
relevant to the gunshot.
When we use an out-of-vocabulary
word like orchestra,
orchestra is not one
of the 41 classes,
we actually retrieve this,
an audio corresponding to Cello,
audio from violin, et cetera.
When we use a more abstract
concept like house,
which is also not
in the 41 classes,
then these are the ones
that other ones I will
retrieve with our approach.
These will be the ones that
we will retrieve if we will
only look at text similarity.
Okay? So of course
the user can argue
which one is more useful in
these more complicated cases.
Now, we do the reverse.
We have a text joint
embeddings pool
and then we're going
to use another query.
So that's the reverse problem.
So in this case, we
have applause and we'll
retrieve applause.
Now, these experiments were
using one standard
deviation of noise.
The number of
nearest neighbors that you
choose to bring the neighbors
affect how many results you get.
In this case, we based on
that same number that we use
for nearest neighbors
which was around 25.
I downloaded an analogy of
applause from free sounds.
Text read and retrieve
the embedding of applause
that was the closest
one to this audio.
>> You mean the text
noise one, okay.
>> Yeah. So now we'll retrieve in
text from the text embedding
pool and we're
using audio queries
that I downloaded
from the web, from Freesounds.
Same with bark it
also will work well.
A gunshot, it didn't bring
the gunshot as a word.
>> You did have
a gunshot in the data.
>> Yes, we did have it
but we didn't get it.
If I would use only all
the audio similarity,
only audio similarity, I
will retrieve these three.
But our approach with
the joint embedding,
audio text joint
embedding retrieve this.
So with orchestra, again
orchestra is added
vocabulary it doesn't
exist in the 41 classes.
So, these are the ones
that I've retrieve
the text embeddings and if
I will have use just the
other similarity I would
retrieve this which
is I think both are reasonable.
Now, this is using
map for retrieval.
Typically, we use mean
average precision and K means
that when I retrieve
the three top results,
I should be able that in
those three results
get the right one.
So, the results look
very close to the
performance that we have
with the accuracy and
classification but these
are slightly better because
we're considering the top three.
>> It's pretty straight, right?
>> Yeah.
K equals five, K equals 10 also.
>> K5.
>> I just use K3 because
that's what they were
using in the literature
this one here.
Of course, if you increase the K,
then most likely you're
going to get better results.
So, we are almost done here.
Then, what was the next step?
So, we have the
cross-modal retrieval
show some relevant results
using the joint embeddings.
We have that also work
well with classification.
We wanted to move
forward to use it with
more complex audio or
more complex tags.
So, just to finalize,
we were working on building
a pipeline where we will
actually used a more
complex idea coming from a,
first of all, we use
an AOL database that has
a lot of query terms.
We want to use
real-search queries.
We pre-process with
the text processing techniques
of our dataset then we created
a crawler to collect
audio and metadata,
tags, and so on from YouTube.
Then this part is very similar
to what I just explained.
Except for this one, we also
included two models one
that is going to generate
synthetic metadata using
speech recognition
and also sound event detection.
So that way we can have
more tags and more information.
Then we compute the features
the way I described before.
Train the joint embedding,
the Siamese Network and then
use it for retrieval and ranking.
Now, this pipeline was complete
but we didn't have time
to actually run it and download
thousands of videos and
recordings and actually test it.
We only did some very
small testing on this.
Anyway, so the conclusion
of this talk is
that the method enables
the cross-modal
classification as well as
retrieval using
the audio and text queries,
and that retrieval results
from the shared latent space
seems preserve similar semantic
between the text and the audio.
I want to thank everyone
for your attention and
thanks Microsoft Research and the
Acoustics Group for
welcoming me here,
it was a really nice time,
and thank you very much
for mentoring in
this summer. Thank you.
>> Is links with
animations. I didn't know.
>> I have a very basic
question as for model.
So, you have a basic
neural network to
include both the audio
and the text.
When you use the same model,
two modalities.
I think that's strange.
If I do this, I will
use one model to embed
the audio and another model to
embed the text and then
try to pull them together.
Thus, here is same
as you are using
the same model or
embed both modality.
>> Right. So, this
particular architecture that
the Siamese Network works
in a way that these
base network each shares
parameter with this one.
So, this one has to be
exactly the same as this one.
>> So, can I
understanding this way.
So, if these two model the same.
So, you want to make
sure the output in
the audio embedding and
the text embedding are similar,
then because you use the same
base and then your audio,
original audio vector and
the original text
vector will also
be the same because
neural network is
continuous embedding.
>> So, let me
board you in to your
little bit to the problem.
So, think about it like this.
In some of these recording
from Inspire speakers,
we have a lot of audio.
Some of these audio can be
elevated, some of it cannot be.
Either you can build a search
engine using just audio.
You can build a search engine
using just the text.
What we're trying to do
is we can make use of
all of this information to
build a richer search engine.
That is what we're trying.
That's the motivation.
You're right, you can
actually train the network to
just extract features of text
and audio in the beginning.
Then, do the Joint
Information Exchange later,
but this is one way of doing it.
You can exchange information with
the base layer and
then combine them.
Sorry, combine them
in the beginning and
just extract a joint
similarity function,
but you can also have
separate layers and then
compute the similarity later.
This is more of
a constraint problem,
which will keep the vectors
in the same space.
>> So, if the original
MCC feature for the audio
is quite different from the
word to vector or the text.
Then, there's no way to really
make the receiving
after the embedding.
Even though they are
inferencing the same concept.
>> So, the more
separate they are,
the harder it is to force them
to be close to each other.
>> Yeah. In fact, I also have
a work on the image
there on the text.
>> Yes.
>> Retrieval task. So, we have
same entering code to the image
feature and another entering code
to the text feature.
The use of perception
to combine them together
to calculate similarity.
We also use it for image
retrieval, attach retrieval.
So, when I see this parameters.
>> So, it's interesting to
compare both approaches.
Both are valid, but I don't
know which one works better.
So, we're trying this
because we thought,
we borrow this a lot from
image and text image search.
People have done the best sector.
People in SITEM was actually
the motivation for this work.
>> Yeah. So, this one.
If you treat them separately,
you will end up with
two networks one that it treats
the text and one that treats
the image or the audio.
In this one is
exactly the same network
to feed audio and text.
So, you can treat them
separately or the same way.
>> Next question, which one
is better, so we don't know.
>> Yeah, I know.
Any question? Good.
>> Can an argument be made that
maybe if you have
a balancing imbalance
in terms of the training data
like you have a lot of audio,
but very little text or
the other way around.
>> Then, it can be harder
to train probably.
>> Yeah.
>> So, if it's balanced,
it might be easier to
train. We don't know that.
So, that's an
experiment definitely
to be done because
I like the idea
you said because I made my view
by data encoding information
from the text.
A different network
might be better in
encoding information
from audio, for example.
>> Yeah, but in the text,
particularly lost
the state sub-sequence.
>> Sure, yeah.
>> Heavily boils the thoughts,
since the sense of sequence.
>> So, using the word direct,
also as part of
the base network might help,
training jointly in this.
That might also be it.
>> Yeah. So, we basically
abstracted out or separated
that feature computation here,
which is different
from familiar text,
but something this
where they actually
connect here that CNN.
It's just fully connected here,
and this one is also
independent where you need
an alignment stage that
needs to be shared by both.
>> In a way work the
back is already.
>> Doing something.
>> Yeah, and same with if
you use a CNN feature.
As you basically
have two machine,
two neural networks
that are separate,
and then ended up.
>> Exactly.
>> They're not jointly
trained, that's the problem.
>> Right.
>> They can be tuned trained,
but I also understand this path.
In this way, you need your basal
and will have
neither capacity because
essentially you are
featuring much larger space.
So, your input space,
you need of the audio
embedded space and
the text embedding space.
So, in this case,
if you want to do,
if you have higher accuracy
than your base should
have neither capacity,
than the way if you
just want to tune on
based on around
the audio space and
another base on the text space.
>> So, there are a lot of ways
of doing this experiment.
The way we started is to actually
start from the last slide.
We've collected all these tags
and everything.
We're not going anywhere.
We realized that it's
really hard to train
the Siamese Network to actually
converge to something.
Then, we realize what you
should simplify that problem and
this is how we start getting and
get presently the final flow.
It looks more control now.
We don't know how
the real types would perform.
It might just not work at all.
So, we don't know. So, we
still evaluating them.
>> I'm not much concerned about
the separate thing of
the two future extractors.
The closer, the more
correlated are they,
the bigger is the risk of
training them separately,
but we just mention that
they are quite different.
So, through inconcorrelated sets,
you can train them separately
without losing much of accuracy.
We can seeing this on
other audio texts as well,
or to make actually brings
a lot of prior information.
>> Yeah.
>> It's more of those that think,
what is the is the coolant
of that to audio.
>> Audio.
>> Audio toothing?
>> Audio too late? Yes!
>> In fact, in my work,
to embed the text, we
do not use vector.
In our case, we are
embedding synthesis,
so each word is just like-
>> Yeah. So, you're basically
paying the whole thing.
>> That's I'm saying.
>> So, you have what to
work within the part
of this network.
>> Yeah, you're
impressing me with this.
>> We can do that, but it's
like a big beast.
Again like I said.
>> Yeah, I will also discuss
about converting this into
a more complicated network CNN.
There's work, actually
where they take the audio.
They also take text for the CNN.
You need sentences.
>> No, this is not
the [inaudible].
So, this is supposed to,
I don't know work in the Cloud,
somewhere along there.
Complication and
all the requirements
are not that will
be safe up there.
>> It's not about comfortation.
I think it's about getting
convergence to this.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> It's really hard. If
you use a complex network,
you don't know where
you're going wrong.
>> Yeah, I think so.
>> All right. Thank you.
>> If you don't have
more questions,
let's give him
a round of applause.